[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation
d'association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Pierre Michel Planchon
coordinateur à l'association metasos qui
organise le festival la tour meliwattes
bonjour bonjour alors chaque année la
tour Mel et les watts est organisée à 50
ans en Yvelines c'est d'ailleurs devenu
un festival incontournable sur sur le
territoire quelle est l'histoire de la
tour elewatts
finalement elle est pas si récente que
ça elle a commencé à voir un peu un
historique parce que anciennement
c'était la tour prend l'air qui existait
de 99 jusqu'à 2011 et du coup la tour
met les watts a été lancé en 2017 pour
sa première édition avec une équipe qui
s'était renouvelée et surtout l'envie de
refaire un festival en plein air sur sur
Voisins-le-Bretonneux quels sont les
ambitions justement autour de ce
festival
bah c'est surtout de faire vivre le
territoire
avant tout d'avoir un espace faire
découvrir des artistes aussi ça c'est
très important et puis à un moment
festif et fédérateur ça c'est vraiment
l'ambition voilà d'avoir ce moment
particulier dans l'année aussi pour
l'association voilà ou c'est un peu la
fête quoi le festival se passe sur deux
jours les deux et trois joints prochain
donc chaque jour six artistes au groupe
se produisent sur 7 c'est un festival en
plein air non loin de Paris est-ce que
chaque année les festivalistes sont au
rendez-vous
j'espère bien oui oui son rendez-vous on
était très surpris l'année dernière
d'ailleurs de la réussite et de
l'engouement du vendredi bon
malheureusement on n'a pas pu faire le
samedi on a une grosse tempête ce qui
nous a contraint à ne pas ouvrir en fait
festival c'était trop dangereux pour
pouvoir accueillir le public donc
c'était une grande grande tristesse en
tout cas public était présent en
rendez-vous et de ce qu'on voit cette
année ça a l'air d'être le cas on est
sur une bonne
une bonne lancée en tout cas pour cette
édition donc on a hâte parce que ça
vient vite là on va parler du coup donc
de la programmation on va commencer par
le vendredi 2 juin on commence avec
mandragore on va écouter un extrait on
poursuit juste après
[Musique]
le 2 juin au festival la tour menée des
watts 5 autres artistes au groupe seront
présents parmi eux Raccoon quel est
l'univers musical de cet artiste le mien
nous sommes dans l'univers dub avec
Raccoon ah ça fait pas mal d'années
maintenant qu'il est sur cette scène là
c'est devenu un vraiment un nom très
reconnu dans le genre donc on est ça
fait quelques années aussi on essaye de
l'avoir dans la programmation du
festival donc cette année c'est bon ça y
est il est programmé festival on est
super content défi réussi finalement
après tant d'années elle l'attendre
exactement dès 2017 c'était des ouais
des bénévoles de
l'association du festival qui nous avait
parlé de cet artiste à titre personnel
que je connaissais pas du tout je suis
allé écouter et vraiment accroché et du
coup bah l'idée elle est restée voilà
quasiment depuis la première édition du
festival d'avoir ce type d'artistes en
tout cas cet artiste en particulier et
ça y est ça se concrétise justement vous
avez dit on l'a découvert donc en 2017
parce qu'on vous en a on vous en a parlé
c'est aussi ça la tournée les watts
c'est des artistes que vous découvrez
que vous souhaitez faire découvrir
exactement et la même soirée donc on
continue sur la programmation le groupe
techno brass qui fera vibrer les
festivaliers qu'est-ce qui nous attend
avec avec ce groupe et bien de la techno
fait avec des cuivres donc ils sont
quand même beaucoup sur scène pas loin
entre 7 et 9 voilà une sorte de fanfare
qui fait voilà qui joue avec leur
instrument et qui fait voilà qui sont en
train de la musique électronique quoi
donc assez incroyable à voir en live
quand même une artiste féminine serait
également présente il s'agit de
ista on va écouter un extrait on
poursuit juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi avoir programmé hista la tour
meliwatts qu'est-ce qui vous a plu dans
son univers musical
ça c'est une sacrée question
[Rires]
bah déjà dans le dans le style un peu
dans le Hardcore c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'avait pas encore vraiment fait
un petit peu l'année dernière on avait
commencé avec Bdx à vouloir s'en
remettre dans une programmation un peu
plus sur les musiques électroniques un
peu plus techno et ben on enfonce le
clou un peu cette année et voilà on
voulait vraiment avoir ce panorama un
petit peu de cette musique là en
invitant mon dragora du coup qui est
plutôt l'univers psytrance et d'avoir
quelque chose aussi qui bon comme on dit
un kit tabasse un clairement c'est
vraiment une artiste là qui est qui
monte depuis des années qui commence à
avoir un sacré nom dans le genre et donc
et puis là je pense que public va être
bien en rendez-vous je pensais attendu
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit pas énormément non plus dans notre
coin ce genre de musique donc c'est
l'occasion justement d'avoir ça et de
pouvoir faire la fête on reste on reste
toujours dans une dans une ambiance très
mouvementée mais à la fois éclectique
finalement au niveau des genres tout à
fait c'est ça que vous avez souhaité
pour pour ce festival aussi
on va poursuivre avec elle 6 mx toujours
le le 2 juin présentez-nous un petit peu
ce groupe alors du coup lgmix pareil on
est dans CLG MX pas L6 MX je sais pas
pourquoi
on est dans l'univers pareil un peu plus
électronique toujours un peu dans cette
mouvance un peu dub aussi de rien qu'on
veut mettre en avant et voilà on a un
plaisir de les faire découvrir pareil
c'est un groupe qui commence à pas mal à
pas mal tourner voilà dans côté région
de Lyon etc nous on aime bien comme
c'est un peu repéré les artistes et
essayer de les d'en inviter un petit peu
de partout
donc là ce qui est vraiment le cas cette
année lorsqu'on a le Mexique qui
représenté le Brésil donc même des
artistes internationaux qu'on a et aussi
les artistes français qu'on met à
l'honneur et enfin le groupe yolamis
sera également présent on va écouter un
extrait on en parle juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc qui fera partie de la programmation
du vendredi 2 juin on va finir cette
interview en parlant un petit peu de
vous de votre association qu'est-ce que
metasos quelles sont ses objectifs
les objectifs de metasos c'est surtout
d'organiser des concerts promouvoir la
musique musical
notamment tout ce qui est musique
amplifiée et pour ça c'est vrai qu'on a
plusieurs activités avec l'association
donc on organise des concerts on gère
des studios de répétition et
d'enregistrement on accompagne des
groupes on organise le festival et
depuis deux saisons on fait même des
ateliers de musique donc on pourra
prendre la musique voilà les instruments
de musique donc c'est vraiment tout
varié autour de la musique pour voilà
que les gens puissent faire de la
musique être sur scène s'exprimer voilà
et surtout animé le territoire ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'il y a de plus important
on a envie de faire vivre les artistes
du coin et aussi inviter des artistes
plus reconnus pour que voilà ce soit sa
bouche quoi et on pourra notamment vous
rencontrer donc lors de ce festival la
tour meliwatts qui aura lieu donc les
deux et trois joints prochain à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines merci beaucoup
Pierre Michel Planchon d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site la tour meliwatt.com on va parler
de la programmation du 3 juin dans une
autre dans une autre émission et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]